and the very first first one costco that
i got is the problem that's here so i
i think it's going to be not difficult
for anybody at the stages to come over
and try to get something
i don't know anyone who has problems
finding well right now when i got the
formula i've seen two three people get
getting formula
from the other side down here yeah i
know a lot of them come to tijuana
to buy
[Music]
this one
it's a the number one they have one two
and three it's pretty it's easy they
have it everywhere at the pharmacies any
store it's just expensive for me it
wasn't difficult and here in tijuana we
can find it in the pharmacies or our
local mall like walmart so we
just go and buy it it's a little bit
expensive but we can get it he's not
able just to get it in the states and
because he knows that right here in
tijuana
it seems like there are plenty of them
well he just asked me like
two hours ago
now that i'm in tijuana if i would be
able just to stop by the casco local
costco store
to see if i can buy the formula for the
babies one of my friends um she lives in
l.a so she's having problems with that
because they're
out of formulas i um buy it here on
costco and tj so i don't have any
problems with uh with that
they're having problems um fandy finding
their family um us so they can just
cross the powder border and then buy it
here in pharmacies or any store
you can find it for me
is
easy because the pharmacy near to my
house is always
they always have the formula
in stock
in my experience i haven't had problems
but i know a lot of moms from a facebook
group
who live in the usa and they're like
crazy trying to get the
the milk and
in my case i buy
a formula from the pharmacy for my
pharmacy so i don't have problems
but i
i know there's a
problem